[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من محاور محاور
اليوم نطرحها مع الباحث في تاريخ الاديان
والحضارات خزعل الماجدي اهلا بك يا دكتور
الماجدي
تحدثنا في حلقه السابقه عن الحضاره
اليمنيه ضمن
السلسله تاريخ الحضارات التي تعمل عليها
وفي هذه السلسله يعني هناك اكثر من مؤلف
لحضارات وادي الرافدين لماذا تعتبرها
حضارات مختلفه وليست حضاره واحده متعاقبه
شكرا لكم الحقيقه وادي الرافدين ومنظومه
الحضارات تختلف عن بعضها في مكان واحد
بدات بالحضاره السومريه ثم الحضاره
الاكاديه ثم الحضاره البابليه ثم الحضاره
الاشوريه
والحقيقه ان لكل واحده من هذه الحضارات
منظومه عناصر ماديه وعناصر ثقافيه
واخلاقيه مختلفه عن الاخرى فبالتالي لا
يمكن جمعها في سله واحده خصوصا ان هناك
نوع من التقاطع
بين هذه الحضارات احيانا فبالتالي هي تعطي
الانطباع بانه وادي الرافدين فيه هذه تسمى
الدول وشعوب واحيانا الامبراطوريات ولكن
في حقيقه الامر ان لكل واحده منها بشكل
حضاري مختلف طيب الحلقه دكتور مجدي
للحضاره الاشوريه والتي خصصت لها بطبعه
الحال مؤلف من جزئين
[موسيقى]
دكتور ماجد مميز الحضاره الاشوريه التي
سادت حتى يعني ثلاثه قرون يعني ربما
الفتره الذهبيه حتى القرن السابع قبل
الميلاد انها كانت ايضا امبراطوريه
لديها نظام سياسي قام على مؤسسه دينيه
ومؤسسه دنيويه يمكن القول والملك طبيعه
الحال المهيمن لكن في الوقت نفسه تقول ان
هذه الحضاره ظلمت
يعني كثيرا في حضاره يعني نعم هناك ذكر
للشعب الاشوري ولما حققه وانجزه لكن ما لم
تذكر كحضاره عند الكثير من المؤلفين سوا
كانوا غربيين او شرقيين او حتى العرب
فبالتالي انا حقيقه يعني بذلت في الجود في
ان اجمع الماده الحضاريه لهذه الحضاره
واصنفوجد انها حضاره كبيره جدا بل تكاد
تكون واحده من اعظم لحضرات في العالم
القديم لماذا لانه هيحتوت على هذه العناصر
بكفاءه كبيره جدا
وذكرني سقوطها بطريقه السقوط التي كانت
بشعه جدا من قبل الجيران وحتى
الاخوينها الذي مثل حضاره البابليه
تحت التراب
واستشاغب ضمير البشري ان يدفونها حتى في
الذاكره ولم تذكر فانا حقيقه طلعتها من
هذا التراب وبدات ابنيه قطعه قطعه الى ان
وضعتها بهذا الشكل المناسب هذه
الجغرافتها الامبراطوريه يعني همم اشتملت
على بلاد المشرق بيكمل يعني اول مره
المشرق يتوحد سياسيا تحت رايه الاشوريين
الذين كان ممتدت الى مصر طبعا ليس الى
طيبه الحقيقه اكثر شيء في الدلتا كانت
موجوده وايضا شمال جزيره العرب ومناطق
الخليج وهمم هذه الحضاره الاشوريه الحضاره
كانت همم كبيره جدا وهي توصف بانها
امبراطوريه عضويه ليست لا تشبه
الامبراطوريات التي سبقتها ولكن سبقتها
كانها امبراطوريات جغرافيه لماذا لان
الحضاره الاشوريه قسمت
يعني خارطه الى ولايات
يعني دقيقه ومحدده يعني النظام الولايات
هنا دخل الذي قلدته الحضاره ال ال ال ال
ال
ال اول مره الاخمينيه ثم
اصبح جزء من فكره الحضاره الرومانيه
للسيطره على العالم
اقصد من كلامي ان هناك امر جديد
تماما حصل مع الحضاره الاشوريه لكنه يهمل
مع الاسف
اصلا هو هذا الموضوع كل كل الحضارات
والانبراطوريات التي في المنطقه كلها كانت
فيها نجعته قل لي من هي التي لم الحضاره
كان يريد
كل كل حتى اليوم
هذا يعني همم القدره العسكريه القدرات
العسكريه وايضا الابتكارات الاشوريه
هو الذي يعني همم يعني اجدها هذه الحضاره
هي كانت تبنيه لسبب بسيط جدا لانها كانت
تغزى من جميع الدول المحيطه بها كل الدول
المحيطه الى الخافه على نفسها فبنت جيش
قوي جدا ثم ظهر باطل عظام جدا في في هذه
الحضاريه كاد يكون اعظم اباطره العالم
القديم
وبنتنا بالشباب لكن المبالغ في هذا
الموضوع المبالغ العسكريه هي التي اصبحت
ثقل مؤذي لهذه الحضاره طبعا ان تقول همم
هناك همم منجزات وانجازات هذه الحضاره
اكبر بكثير من الصفه الغالبه او المتداوله
عنها بانها قائمه على فقط القوه
بسيط جدا المنجزات العلميه في الحضاره
التي لا تقطر على بال احد
منجزات هائله جدا يعني على المستوى
الفيزيائي انجز السدود والقصور
يعني
حتى استخدمت قانون ارخميدس في رفع الماء
قبل ارخميدس بحوالي 400 500 سنه يعني اقصد
ان هناك منجزات كثيره جدا عملت كتب كامله
موجود همم المنجزات الطبيه هائله جدا لهذه
الحضاره كتاب الجيب الطبي
والعدسات كانت يعني اكتشف وجود عدسات يعني
حتى العدسات هم اكتشفوها
حتى في سكوبات
يعني
النظام السيا
الذي قام في الامبراطوريه شوي يمكن القول
انه كان في نوع من ليس مرور الفصل المعنى
المتداولون بين الدين والدوله لكن من هناك
واضحه الامور انما هو للملك وما هو همم
الدوله الاشوريه في ان ال ال ال الم
المظهومه الدنيويه او المدنيه هي التي
تسيطر على المنظومه الدينيه لم تسمح لكانه
عاشور ان يستخدموها كما حصل في همم في
البابليه هذا انا البابليه
هم الذين سيروها لكن في الحضاره الاشوريه
لن يسمح للمؤسسه الدينيه ان تضغط عليه
ولذلك كان من الناحيه العمليه هو رئيس
المؤسسه الدينيه يعني محترم وفي مكان لا
يسمح
للرجال الدين ان يتدخلوا بعمله وهذا متاكد
من شيء معروف جدا عند الاشوريين وهو ان
ال-
صفه الاله اشوري لاول مره تتغير في وادي
الرافدين لا على انه اله تفريج فقط وانما
اسميته بالبنفيزم اللي هو اله شامل وهكذا
رفع الاله اشور الى مصافي قريبه من
التوحيد كيف اثر فيما بعد هذا التراث
السوري على الاديان توحيديه
خصوصا في اليهودي
يعني الدراسات قليله في هذا الموضوع وانا
انا اشرت في الكتاب الى هذه الامور لكني
فيما بعد بصراحه افردته كتابا جديدا
ساتحدث فيه عن الديانه الاشوريه وكيف اثرت
على الجرادشتيه وكانت مساهمه في نموذج
لانه فكره اله العالمين
يعني لما نيجي ندرسها بشكل دقيق نجدها
مجسده بشكل واضح جدا عند الاشوريين باكثر
من غيرهم ثم ليس هذا حتى النظام الكهنوت
حتى كل التفاصيل والرموز يعني تخيل رمز ال
ال ال الدوله الاشوريه والحضاره الاشوريه
باكملها
وهو يمسك بالقوس هو نفس هذا الرمز هو هو
رمز ده نفسه يعني حرفين طبعا مرسوم بطريقه
اخرى لكن اقصد من كلامك كان لها تاثير
كبير جدا
من تاثيرات الحضاره الاشوريه تتحدث انها
كانت نوع من الرابط
عبر الفنون هذا الموضوع مهم جدا اثرته في
الكتاب كنت من يتشائل كيف وصلت حضاره وادي
الرافدين الى الاغريق وهمم وهناك
دالات كثيره جدا على ان هناك عناصر
الرافدين بشكل العام همم موجوده في
الحضاره الاغريقيه فعرفت تماما ان
الاشوريين كانوا هم السبب لماذا لان
الامبراطوريه الاشوريه امتدت الى كل
تقريبا اغلب اسيا الصغرى وعلى تخوم
المتوسط وهناك كانت شعوب اغريقيه اسيويه
هي التي نقلت عناصر يعني مثلا العمود
الايونيه العمود الكره في العماره في
العماره ال- همم في العماره الاغريقيه كان
موجود اصلا مرسوم ومعمول به في عند
الاشوريين وامور كثيره الاخرى جدا على
سبيل المثال انا دائما اقول هذا
النحت والعماره
الاشوريه
الاشوريه كانت ملهمه جدا بالنسبه
الرومان يعني هذه العماره الضخمه هل يمكنك
ان تتخيل ان
قصور همم
الملوك كان فيها ما يقرب جداريات من
كيلومتر كامل منحوته نحت يعني يعني بنحكي
البارجي يسموه وعبر يعني قطع من المعدن
لما نحاس او برونز كانت موجوده على طول او
يعني على عرض هذه القصور كيلو متر يعني
هذا الانجاز معماري هائل جدا والشخصيه
الاشوريه
كانوا امه وهناك اثنيات متعدده استطاعوا
دمج همم مختلف الالف
ضمنهم
اي ناس
يعني يوضعون في امبراطورتهم اشوريه
يعني اي انسان يعني هو كان من بلاد الشام
من يوضع يمتلك حريه المواطنه الاشوريه ولا
يفرق مع الاشوري كانوا يريدون باعتبار ان
الجناح يعني الاله اشور يرفوا عليه
روحي
كامل الحريه في في ممارسه عقائدهم الدينيه
ولكن يجب ان يحترموني الى الشرطه
الى مباحث دقيقه جدا
الاشوريين هم نفسهم اهل تلك الحضاره لكن
طبعا عندما دخل فقط
وبمجرد تبدل الكتابه وطريقه الايمان كذا
اصبحنا امام اا نوع من الادغام تلك
الحضارات في بعضها تحت غطاء مسيحي لكن
نشاهد انه فيما بعد يعني لما مر الزمن
افاق الجميع على انهم كانوا اصحاب حضاره
وتميز فبداوا يستعيدون تلك الحضارات
باسمائهم الجديده يعني هي يعني والاشور
والسوريان مثلا
ويتلابزون بها مع الاسد في حين هم كلهم
ابناء امه واحد قديمه والمفروض ان الواحد
يكمل للاخر
وليس واحد يلف الاخر كما يحصل الان بفعل
دين وسياسي حاج جدا
سوري رغم كل شيء
نعمل اعتزاز بالتراث
السوريان يعتقدون انه ما دامت كل هذه
الامور تحدثت السرياني او الاراميه
السوريه يعني فيما بعد اذن يعني الكل لكن
انا اعتقد انه
طاء الحقوق الصحيحه او تاريخ الصحيح لكل
شعب هو المطلوب وهذا ما حاولت القيام
السوري
بعيده عن المساله
اهتزاز بالماضي او قراءه الماضي ما اهميه
قراءه حضاره الاشوريه اليوم او الحذاء او
غيرها من الحضارات الرافدين طبيعه الحال
يعني بعصرنا اليوم
الحقيقه الشيء المهم دائما هذا يمكن تردد
السؤال ان الاشوريين غبنوا بكل صراحه يعني
[موسيقى]
كبير جدا يعني حتى من ابناء جلدتهم حتى من
من اهل وادي الرافدين نفسه او من العراق
الحديثه فانا اعدت الاعتبار لهم باعتبار
ان هذه الحضاره الاشوريه والحضاره
البابليه والحضاره الاكاديه والحضاره
السومريه هي كلها يعني
مناطق مشعه في وادي رم
يعني
كل واحده نعطيها حقه وبذلك تمشي الامور
بشكل طبيعي وتعزز شخصيه العراق الجديد بان
حضراتك كانت بهذا الشكل وحتى ما تلاها
فيما بعد الاسلام وتكون الحضاره الاسلاميه
كانت بغداد عاصمه هذه الحضاره البلد يعني
لا يجب ان ننابز او نتنابز بانه هذا افضل
من وهذا وهي كلها شيء متكامل هذا ما حصل
في التاريخ وعلينا ان لا نهمل قصاصه ورقه
واحده هل ترى ان هناك همم تركيز اكثر على
التاريخ
ما بعد الاسلام على حساب ما قبل طبعا مع
الاسف الشديد ديانات التوحيد هي كلها
وليست فقط لاسلام الاسلام والمسيحيه للاسف
نظره وحتى اليهودي نظروا الى الحضارات
التي سبقتهم نظره احتقار من خلال مبدا دين
الوسيط وكفروها اعتبروها يوم الجمعه كفار
وانا خطا جسيم يعني تركيب الان لابد من
اعاده الاعتبار لهذه الحضارات
ماذا انجزت للبشريه هل خدمت البشريه ام لا
يعني من الاعتبار مدني وانساني وليس من
اعتبار ديني كونها همم عباده ما عبدت هذا
امر طبيعي كان يشمل العالم باكمله فلا يجب
ان يحصل الناس في هذا القفص يجب ان نركز
على الانسانيه والجوانب المدنيه لان
الحضارات تعني التمدن تعني المنجز الحضاري
المدني وبالتالي هذه الحضارات لها منجز
حضاري مدني عظيم جدا وبضمنها ايضا
الحضارات المسيحيه والاسلاميه الجانب
المدني من وجهه نظري هو الاهم هو الذي
يعطيها صفه الحضاره جانب الدنيا يعني يكون
طاغي وموجي للجوانب الاخرى
فانا منهجي في الشغل هو هذا انصف كل هذه
العناصر لا اعطي عنصرا على حساب عنصر اخر
لكن اشير للخطا ان وجد عندما يضغط جانب
الديني على على على
البقيه اقول هذا حتى استاذ وسيم حتى في
الحضاره المدنيه الحديثه لا يجوز ان يضغط
الجانب المادي بكامله على الحضاره المدنيه
يجب ان يدينا هذا الطهيان ويجب ان يعيد
الاعتبار للجوانب الروحيه والجماليه
والاخلاقيه التي يجب ان تنهض الحضاره
الحديثه التي طغى فيها مع الاسف بجانب
والاقتصادي شكرا لك يا دكتور خزعل
الماجيدي على المشاركه في محل شكرا
لكم مشاهدينا والى اللقاء في حلقه جديده
من محاور
[موسيقى]